notre correspondant à l'Ukraine nous
rejoint de Kiev bonjour Emmanuel que
sait-on de ses évacuations annoncées
dans la région de kaki
les autorités ukrainiennes ont demandé à
la population toujours sur place
d'évacuer au moins dans la ville la plus
proche de la ville de harkif qui se
trouve environ 90 km de copiens alors
c'est
ces conseils aux habitants ces
évacuations déjà en cours de la
population elle s'applique aux habitants
de croupion ce qui s'applique aussi à
plus de 30 communes alentours on parle
d'une population qui si elle n'a pas
évacuée et souvent on est souvent pas en
moyen
pas en capacité de le faire je pense aux
personnes âgées je pense aux personnes
en situation de handicap à mobilité
réduite aux enfants aux familles qui
accompagnent des personnes en difficulté
sauf que les autorités ukrainiennes
devant les avancées russes et devant le
danger également représenté par les
frappes de missiles quotidienne russe
sur c'est sur ces cartes sur ses
habitations sur de ces villages et bien
les autorités en joignent très fortement
la population a quitté les lieux afin
qu'elles ne se retrouve pas prises entre
les deux armées je rappelle que couper
ce que comme les communes aux alentours
avaient été occupés pendant pendant près
de 6 mois jusqu'à la Libération en
septembre dernier par les forces
ukrainiennes de la région de harkis les
forces russes semblent se rapprocher
avec le ministère de la Défense russe
qui affirme que ces troupes ont avancés
et qu'elles ont amélioré leur position
dans la région par ailleurs Emmanuel
l'Ukraine dit avoir ouvert des couloirs
temporaires pour des navires en mer
Noire pour transporter ces céréales or
on le sait la zone est sous blocus russe
et la Russie a déjà prévenu que les
bâtiments en question pour être
considéré comme des cibles légitimes
oui alors attention il s'agit de
corridor horaires pour les pour ceux des
navires qui avaient été bloqués dans les
ports Ukrainiens depuis l'an dernier
depuis le début de la bloca du blocus
russe en mer Noire alors la marine
ukrainienne a affirmé abordé
l'itinéraire de ces corridors
temporaires à l'Institut à
l'organisation pardon international
maritime en revanche si de tels voyages
ont lieu il se feront à la discrétion
des capitaines de navire qui devront
prendre cette décision qui a fait
annoncer qu'il y aurait tout un
dispositif de surveillance qu'il y
aurait des caméras à bord de chaque
navire afin de prouver au monde entier
qui ne s'agit pas de cargaison militaire
et également de de pouvoir rendre compte
en cas d'incident quand je pense à un
aux incidents je pense notamment aux
mines qui se trouve en mer Noire mais
également au possible attaques russes
contre de tel navire puisque il ne faut
pas oublier que la Russie a bien précisé
que tout navire entrant en quittant les
ports Ukrainiens seraient considéré
comme une cible potentielle car pouvant
possiblement acheminer de l'équipement
militaire Emmanuel chaise à Kiev merci